hello and welcome to this video playing
fo rism and I'm going to go a form for a
change get some variety going um can i
play something offbeat ish maybe this
one not not a mainline father for this
game this is not a bad setup i believe
here it's a little bit like the cop or
system with reversed colors even though
i don't have to play Knight c3 like I do
here I think c3 is also possible yeah I
was just thinking about this yeah maybe
he has this move and team played it ok
I'm going out of this this potential
Knight b6 tempo it might be that he can
play against the d3 pawn yeah with
Bishop f5 and those those kind of moves
oneida for I've learned at 94 oops oops
so very big groups a stupid 93 yeah just
wanted to go to see 44 and it's usually
you see it right the moment you play it
wow it's very very tough to come back
from blundering a big center pond Wow
yeah big Center porn and the bishop Pam
at least I've got some somewhat decent
development yeah i was thinking Queen f4
here to activate all right okay maybe
maybe this is actually not not that bad
I was a bit uh Maggie five put me off
but Queen g3 is not that bad really I
was a quick decision and that somewhat
dangerous Queenie 8 he pretty much has
to do that Bishop d7 looks very strange
Queenie ain't Bishop t5 Bishop e7 hmm
and I get quite some selectivity here
that gets interesting after my blunder
I have enough for the pond you know for
sure I wonder what is investing time on
because 28 is the only move what else
Bishop d7 OPD to remodel then he can
resign immediately I think aha whoa why
is that even working check always
Queenie a tall so terrible and I didn't
see why black resigns huh that's weird
yeah I mean that that's really really
and those kind of games always
frustrating for the opponent the same is
this for me and the other guy blunders
place horribly and then all of a sudden
they get some compensation out of
nothing ya Yin I'd be detours of course
terrible I think the position he has
equal maybe it's not ideal of what
happened to you for me I would rather
like this position with the pawn back
hem for example why him not having
played 25 at all maybe this one is
better I also maybe can do this I don't
think that this is a terrible i QP
position one reason is that he has
played age 60 if he plays Bishop e6 for
example I always have this interesting
possibility it's probably not working
right here not objectively athletes yeah
also because it can always second back
there were okay this is ridiculous move
him so I think this is definitely all
fine by black be 6v6 I have to say I was
a little bit skeptical because of the
weakness of the diagonal the engine is
still fine with black hair okay here
Bishop a sick
that was a good move 9 a-5 I found very
surprising especially after that
relatively short thinking time but it
seems that I win anyway but I didn't see
at all the app issue 86 first of all
this is what black should do gaining
this temple on the on the look and after
this he has screen to be idea this makes
a lot of sense yeah this is more or less
objectively speaking of win yet he's got
a central pawn extra and and the bishops
so it's it's just very good and then
don't have a serious attack I mean okay
I think actually in a blitz game there's
still some hope because I have some good
active pieces but objectively this is
very bad and here I'm already winning
this I didn't see you will have to
create oh my god 96 ah that's the
problem okay so when I was saying I
don't understand why he isn't moving
that is the thing he saw simply he saw
more than I did he saw this line yeah I
don't know maybe I would have found it i
don't think so maybe I was thinking I
was thinking this is something that I
could play because i saw this i saw this
line let's say and then invasion here
which looks like okay you know does this
cannot be bad for white but of course 96
is just the end of the game yeah then he
is lost ya that this was pretty obvious
and then you try to be five but okay i
can change just smash em yeah here i'm
winning check winning the house the
house and if he moves the king this is a
full full look for absolutely nothing
yeah very lucky win after this miss with
night
them to have form ok guys thanks for
watching